hi this is Chris Baker senior editor at
Wired magazine and today we're talking
to Alex Evans who is a co-founder of
Media Molecule maker of the brilliant
game LittleBigPlanet
hi everyone thanks for coming out on the
rainy day I'm not going to talk that
much about LittleBigPlanet at the
beginning I'm gonna give a little intro
because I don't know how much you guys
do or don't know about the game one of
the interesting things about use
generated content is it's an evolving
thing right so we haven't got there yet
with a little big planet and I think the
games industry and you know web 3.0 and
game 9.0 and all those things are still
kind of exploring how users can be
empowered and a lot of people when we
were pitching a little big planet to
Sony who published it we're saying what
is this game is it a game even is it the
sandbox is it a linear experience who's
it for what's the demographic all the
normal questions and the more we got
through the development the more
confusing that got because it seemed to
work for kids and adults and boys and
girls and everyone basically and even
worse it's a platformer game but hang on
you can also create stuff with it and I
found it easier to present the game to
non gamers who were less keen to
pigeonhole it gamers tend to want to
know precisely what it is that they're
gonna get whereas none game is a happy
to hear that it's fun and you can make
stuff and you can upload it and share it
with your your friends or the wider
community what we do at Media Molecule
and this is a kind of big part of what I
think users are doing increasingly on
the web is communicating visually so
camera phones these days you know every
laptop these days has a little camera in
it
images are all around and we decided
when we were starting the studio three
years ago that we would communicate with
each other very visually through demos
and through video to the extent that in
fact rather than presenting to our
publisher our work as a checklist of
this is what we did this month we
actually ran around the studio with a
handycam and buttonholed people and I've
got some of that footage to show just
like us rambling to camera getting
excited about what we're doing and this
was the first thing that we ever created
and we pitched to Sonia's
if you like the genesis of what became
the play part of what we call play
create and share watch the little
controller in the bottom left of the
screen because that is the only input
there are no button presses here it's
only left analog stick and right analog
stick and there's no pre-canned
animation what we did was we wired your
exact physical movements to the
movements of the character and so you
have what you think going back to my top
general theme user-generated content
it's this massively broadchurch a lot of
people see it as a narrow thing that
maybe seems poor which is an amazing
game in which you go from a sort of
single-celled organism all the way
through to a complete space enabled
civilization but in fact the Me's
generated content started right when
game started with games cabinets that
got graffiti'd or even my favourites of
people who used to write messages like
hi mom how are you using the three
character initials on the high school
table and they would they'll get each
score and turn in order to send messages
that that's user-generated content and
you have games like populist and my
background is from a game company called
bullfrog which was founded by Peter
Molyneux and so I've always worked in
that kind of God game genre as it's
called sandboxes and the American
SimCity and will write who ended up
making spore is been pioneering in those
areas and again that's that's kind of
user-generated content and then you have
this interesting other area of access if
you like of how complicated it is so
there's meat there's sing style which is
a karaoke game which is huge in Europe I
think it's just come out over here this
year and the latest version you can
upload yourself crooning badly to
whatever tune and that is if you like
this extreme easy end of user-generated
content you have things like line rider
which is a flash game where you just
give the person a tiny tiny simple tool
namely drawing a line and people create
these kind of Japanese woodcut esque
incredible panoramas give them an inch
and they'll take a mile that was what we
learned from the line rider and moving
up the spectrum you get two games like
echo chrome on the PSP and it doesn't
matter if you haven't seen these games
but there's the idea is that there's
this continual kind of
Vectren that you can tap into depending
on how much of a gamer how much of a
creative kind of person you feel you are
you've got the spore creature editor
which is which is an amazing piece of
technology and at the extreme end you
have the modding tools which effectively
speaks to an audience for a few thousand
maybe or a few tens of thousands but
they can create a game of the same
quality there's any developer so where
does LittleBigPlanet for well we thought
console game is a piece of pop culture
it's like a beautiful coke can of
simplicity in theory so we wanted to
fall in the middle of that spectrum and
find a way to engage it wide an audience
as possible and get them interested in
creating so that we took some of the
flexibility of editors like that but
tried to strip away the the kind of
barrier and the way we did that was
through the character sackboy so what is
a little big planet is it a tool is it a
game is it a again very hard to explain
until you bring into it this kind of
idea of of a character so here's a
little video where we were explaining to
Sony about that and why we just
redesigned them LittleBigPlanet is a
wise wondrous world the denizens of
which are always on the moon play back
the adventuring a moment of reflection
however begs the question here this will
give you
mischievous sack people are not just
residents of this wacky world they also
help to build it there are natural
architects Linda create whether to food
for the flame
the set boy is empowered by his puppet
tool fascinating adaptation the
seemingly magic wand through the proper
tool sack boy can get through this
goodie bag of tricks observe as he pops
it instant goodies this bag houses many
types of cardboard metal stone and wood
materials like wood each material has
its own physical properties stones
obviously might tell you the cardboard
and sponges can be gripped whereas most
materials cannot there are also some
rare elements with strange special
properties like buoyant bubbles this sad
girl is building platforms out of dark
matter which will float indefinitely as
if to say Isaac Newton was full of hooey
creating objects and shaping shapes is
fast and fun like Michelangelo chiseling
away at stone to uncover the daily
hidden underneath the SEC we work our
scale and rotate his materials to his
liking the most advanced creators make
full use of items in their tool a sack
people love to tweak out motors Pistons
and propulsion devices cream some very
to rise another one of the wondrous
possibilities made possible with the
tool bag is the ability to trigger fears
to move emitters to shoot explosive
things to will without supports items to
observe the natural laws of nature
although they can be temporarily
suspended in midair through the pause
command but what a set boy makes a
mistake you may ask well sack people
rewind or fast-forward accidents away
in order to create a truly exhilarating
experience element of danger must be
present hand-picked from the periodic
tables of the elements of danger sack
people can lethal eyes objects setting
them aflame charging them full of
high-voltage electricity or simply
letting out some killer casts the SEC
will also make use of pre-made enemies
or whip up some fresh-baked ones it's up
to the Creator to define the enemy
artificial intelligence from aggressive
to apathetic or just downright pathetic
before it's time to play final touches
ready including the addition of stickers
and decorations even using the
PlayStation Eye for a special touch of
flair the level is almost complete sack
wood places his spawn points starting
and ending gates and checks his head now
will the fun part
Sackboy invites his friends over to go
wild in this newly created world in
addition to playing together the sack
people don't should work together
simultaneously rebuilding and
redesigning its ever-expanding worlds
Bravo on our final visit with a big bet
I'll show you where these completed
levels go as we observe the act of
sharing exact people communities so
there's kind of a lot of different
mechanisms I'm going to zoom back out
again and talk about user-generated
content in that abstract way of like
we're disarming you we're trying to make
a statement within this broad Church as
I call it a views er generated content
and I'm really looking forward to seeing
what the games industry does to exploit
this idea that people have a latent
desire to create something even if they
don't realize it it's the same way that
you know when blogging came about
perhaps a lot of people didn't realize
that they particularly wanted to blog
but when they found that they could
communicate or when they could Facebook
and reach old friends or or current
update people on Twitter all these
different social mechanisms which are
popping up on the web I think will be
rediscovered within a games medium as
well where people who didn't necessarily
know they wanted to to do user-generated
content
actually just enjoy it and enjoy the act
of creation as much as the act of say
shooting or racing people become really
attached to it and quite violently sort
of they become advocates of the game but
through their version of it like check
my version that'll be put out it's not
the same as your version and this
actually first came up we didn't realize
this and until after we had finished the
beta trial where we'd assumed that the
content would be pretty ropey in the
same way that YouTube maybe a fraction
of a percent of people actually upload
content and the majority of people go
there to consume well the same is the
same as the case with LittleBigPlanet
however we were really shocked at the
number of levels that went up on the
Vita trial and the quality of them
especially because they only had a tiny
amount of the content with which to
create and so our original plan to ditch
all of the beta content was in
retrospect obviously wrong but at the
time we said right what we're gonna fail
it away because obviously it was rubbish
and the community went mental rightly so
you know we did a we did a chart because
I couldn't convince various people that
we should keep the content and so we did
a poll and interestingly this included
people who didn't take part in the beta
trial which is a very limited experience
and the argument for throwing away the
content was this there are hundreds of
thousands of people who buy the game on
day one want to be the first in they
want to be the vote you know the virgin
snow effect of being the first person to
make the call snow angel make the first
level but no interestingly Alps you know
huge majority of people even those who
hadn't had the chance to play the beta
wanted to keep that content and I think
the reason that changes sequels is
because people make a massive personal
investment in the game which is not the
case with other kinds of gameplay so
what are we going to do for a little bit
planet - well hopefully the same amount
of effort will go into a little bit
planet - but I don't want to ship it as
a traditional sequel that's not to say
we won't I mean I it may be that down
the line that's the route we take but
what fascinates me is finding a way
where if you spent a hundred hours
making some you know physical website we
call them some of the levels aren't even
at
to play they're just kind of statements
they're just kind of sandboxes if this
is my bedroom recreated using my I toy
photos and how do we extend a little big
planet without making that all of that
great work be thrown away and that
that's art going to be our key strategy
is to expand the game while well without
partitioning the audience I mean I'm
going to show you funhouse because it's
both representative of a user made level
good user made level but also of the
types of levels that you get that we
ship with the game okay I'm just I'm
just not gonna go there but um I'll pick
a different one I'll pick an easier one
so there's no way in the game of
uploading your own music but we provided
a single block that made a sort of piano
noise and this was the result now to
appreciate this level in its entirety
you will have to play the game and try
creating and it is easy to create but
every single one of those drum hits
samples was individually tuned up and
down we didn't help we didn't imagine
that people will create music for this
game they've been arranged physically
and there were tiny little kind of
hundred and hundred and hundreds of
switches which are detecting that you're
nearby and triggering the sounds I mean
it's absolutely mind-blowing the sort of
OCD madness and this is the kind of
given an inch they'll run a mile thing
if you like a level you can you can
favorite it or you can find more by the
author and you get this kind of so this
guy Suki has been pretty prolific and
you actually get a social element to use
generated content which i think is going
to be pivotal to any game that that
builds these kind of ideas and that's
what's changed between the old user
generated content games that I mentioned
things like Sim City things like
populist or even things like the
shoot-'em-up construction kits of the of
the 8-bit era they had no means of
publication and distribution and the
internet or all in the case of the
PlayStation 2 PlayStation Network
provides that platform for you to
broadcast yourself and that's why I
think this is genuinely a new and new
trend and a new thing for games I really
encourage you if you have a PlayStation
2 to have a go on this game find a
friend who has it buy a copy even better
and you find you get lost in this kind
of weird world of good and bad levels
not everything is brilliant not
everything will be your taste but about
one time in four or five I find you just
find something really surprising so I do
encourage you to go and have a look at
the sort of breadth of what's what's
come out of LittleBigPlanet